[Music]
I sure yeah being a venture first man to
walk on the moon may be something we've
chosen a job so difficult requiring so
many technological developments we're
gonna have to start from scratch
only after we mastered these tasks do we
consider trying to land on the moon Neil
if his flight is successful you'll go
down in history what kind of thoughts do
you have about that we're planning on
the flight being successful
and that is a big mother it'll go up
like a half kiloton to a bomb if it
blows the vehicles not safe
to fail down here so we don't fail up
there this isn't just another trip Neal
you're not was going to work
he said you're coming back
there are risks but we have every
intention of coming back
somebody got a Swiss Army knife Swiss
Army knife any question whether the
program is worth the cost in money in
and last you down here and you look up
and you don't think about it too much
but space exploration changes your
perception and it allows us to see
things that we should have seen a long
time ago we have serious problems
we've got this under control you're a
bunch of boys you don't have anything
for the control
[Music]